Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in the final sentences
of chapter number 74
of the book of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
the supreme Quran
verse number 20
here we have Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
commanding the establishment of prayer.
And we mentioned before that the
difference between making prayer praying
and establishing prayer is that in order
for a person to be considered to have
established prayer,
they have to have prayed fulfilling all
of what
conditions
ish
aren and pillars
and
wajibet obligations. Correct. Those
three
conditions, pillars, obligations.
When a person fulfills those conditions,
pillars and obligations, they have now
established prayer.
Allah Subhanahu Wa'ta'ala then says,
This is a repeating statement in the
Quran. Allah subhanahu wa ta uses this
language
very consistently.
It could be translated as give zaka.
But the question here especially for
those Arab speakers
because the details
is where the precision and beauty comes
and where the dynamics and nuances come
out. This is what inspires action. This
is what is truly the point of reflecting
on the book of Allah. What is another
word for?
If we wanted to word it differently for
the Arab speakers, how would we word it?
Right? So here we have two words.
Those are two words. But you notice that
in the Quran, these two words are not
used interchangeably.
They are used in very specific ways
because they both carry different
connotations.
just any group of synonyms, all
synonyms, if we were to take a five
synonyms, let's say, of a single word,
they all meet at a common intersection
of meaning. Correct?
But then each of them carries an
additional meaning that the other
doesn't. That's the point of synonyms
and that's how synonyms work especially
in the Quran. So we have for instance
they both intersect
and are both common commonly
to mean used to mean to give.
But what is the difference between them?
If we look through the Quran
and we try to
focus on the places where Allah uses the
word
that root word and any of its
derivatives and
and that root word of any and any of its
derivatives,
we start to see a pattern.
And this pattern
articulates
a main difference between
is that is to give something
and that thing does not necessarily
that is not something that you are
giving as
a gift. Let's say if I were to give
someone a gift, I would not use the word
I would use the word.
Notice this in the Quran Allah says
so Allah uses
with the book that was sent to
but then when he speaks about something
specific
he says
so here he's speaking to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam saying we
have given you Muhammad the Kther the
kar is the river
one of its meanings is the river from
paradise that the prophet sallallah
alaihi wasallam described to us now
what's the difference between those two
in his book he mentions that one of the
differences between
is that
is not necessarily the recipient doesn't
necessarily
own that and is able to
dis you know able to use his own
discretion it's for him only that is not
the way is used that is used for when I
use the word
it means it's for you you can do
anything you want for with it and And
it's something that you weren't
necessarily owed and it's something that
is very personal and it's used with
gifting
contrary to
Allah says
first of all
received the zab it's guidance from
Allah
and it is not just for him to his
discretion he has to distribute it. He
has to show it. He has to reveal it. He
has to teach it to others. It's not his
personal property. It doesn't belong to
him.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala uses the same
language with respect to the Quran.
He says subhanahua
that we have given you seven oft
repeating verses and the rest of the
Quran with it. Here we see the same
language. It's not for you. It's not
your property. It's not to your
discretion.
This is a responsibility. It's given to
you and it is for a very particular
reason. It's to be shared with others.
But
that's usually used to articulate what?
Total discretion.
When I give you a a present, a gift,
this now means that it's your property.
You can do with it whatever you want.
What's the point of all this? We are to
say, okay, great. Those are nice points.
But what is the point of that with
respect to
the language of
often
carries the connotation of doing
something extra, something that you
didn't really have to do, something that
you know belongs to you and you're
doing it as a favor to someone else. But
no, not necessarily
a zaka. Let's say I have some zaka to
give that zaka when I earn my money and
I fit the conditions and pillars of
zaka. So now zaka's obligated that 2.5%.
Does that 2.5% belong to me? The person
who earned it. I earned it. It's my
sweat. It's my sweat and my blood and my
tears. How can you tell me it's not
mine? Does it belong to me? No, it never
did belong to me. It never did belong to
me. I am acting as a conduit for that
two 2.5% in this in this instance
doesn't belong to me. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says that it belongs to the
recipients
belongs to the poor.
that these these they belong they are
the right of the poor and the needy etc.
the eight different types of people that
receive zaka the prophet sallallah alaii
wasallam
he tells us or Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
he tells us with respect to
He says regarding the believers, they
are the ones who have in their wealth,
in their accumulation of wealth, a set
percentage that is known that is the
belonging of those who are in need. It
doesn't belong to him. And so there the
use of the word
this carries the connotation of doing
someone a favor. It's a gift. I'm
giving it to someone. It's I'm so great
because I'm doing this for people that
never belonged to me. I am doing the
bare minimum by giving zak.
This is what is understood from the
meaning of
deliver.
That is a better translation than give
zakat or pay alms. Often times it is
translated as give those who give zaket.
It's okay. Better yet those who deliver
zaket because it never belonged to them.
It wasn't theirs in the first place. And
if they were to keep it, they didn't
keep their own wealth. They kept wealth
that belonged to someone else. It is the
same as stealing out of people's
pockets.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam commands us with giving zaka
and then he said Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala commands us saying
establish prayer
and deliver a zak
and give to Allah a good loan
a good loan.
A pure loan. Give to Allah
a pure loan.
What does this mean?
What is meant by alone here?
Why does Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala use
this language?
Because a loan
is something that
essentially if you give a loan to a
trustworthy person,
did you really lose any money?
You get it? You get back exactly
what it is you gave correct.
That money didn't go anywhere. Didn't
disappear. You didn't lose any money.
That money was merely
used for something. and then give him
back to you. That's how a loan works.
And so that loan is something that is
guaranteed
for you
to get that loan back to get that money
back or that that is something which is
guaranteed for you. And so Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala uses the language of
loaning
not because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is
in need but to articulate the guarantee
of Allah that not one dime will go
unreturned,
not one penny will go unreturned,
not one cent will go unrewarded. and
unreturned.
And another point of a loan is that this
loan is usually what out of goodness
when I loan someone something, this is a
favor that I'm doing for someone.
Correct? And so because of this, because
of the meanings that the connotations
that the word loan carries, some of the
scholars of TS say the meaning of this
verse is establish prayer, deliver a
zaka, and give additional
charity to be that which is beyond a
zaka.
And that loan has to be what? It has to
be good.
Allah says
it has to be a good loan, a pure loan.
What is a pure loan? Who could tell us
what are the descriptions
of a pure loan? something that is hass
What what distinguishes a good loan from
a bad loan?
[Arabic recitation]
good. He mentions
so the money itself has to be pure
halal. Okay, that's correct as well.
Huh?
Meaning that it's something that is not
used for bad. Correct. Isn't that a
descriptions of
sincere? When you give it sincerely,
that's
the money itself is pure. it hasn't come
from a bad source.
Number three, that it is not used for a
bad thing. Correct? This as well is all
of these things fall into the generality
of a pure and good loan. What about also
having
giving it in if I were to
give it disgruntledly?
I don't want to give this but you know
just whatever take it. Is that good?
Huh?
Right.
That the that the heart is pure in
giving it. It's not disgrunt
disgruntled. The heart is not
begrudgingly
giving this loan. It is something that
you are giving and you're giving it with
enthusiasm.
Correct? All of these meanings that were
just mentioned now are all meanings that
the scholars and have mentioned with
respect to the meaning of
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam tells
us
Allah is good and pure and he only
accepts that which is good and pure.
And our prophet sallall.aii wasallam
tells us that whoever
gives something for other than the sake
of Allah then Allah will forsake him and
whatever he has worshiped with that
intention of his. Correct? And likewise
as Allah as Abu Ali mentions for
instance that it be used for a good
thing. The prophet sallallah or Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says
all of these meanings and more all fall
into the generality of
we have learned today the difference
between
and that
we understand that it's just something
we're delivering one Another important
part point of that is that if I
understand if I'm giving zakat
and I understand that this zaka this
money that I'm giving never belonged to
me. It belongs to the person who
receives it. It belonged to them. Always
did. As soon as it was eligible for zaka
immediately it was belonging to them.
Would I ever reproach someone for giving
them zaka?
No.
[Arabic recitation]
You know, I gave you a lot of zak. What'
you do with it? Tell me. I just gave you
a bunch of zak. You're already broke
again. Come here. Let's talk about that.
What' you do with it? You know that was
a that was a big chunk of money I gave
you. What' you do with that? Huh? What'
you do? You spend a little something on
yourself. What' you do with it? Right.
All of this behavior, this all comes
from what? A heart that doesn't
understand what it's doing.
Or
you know, I'm going to give you this and
you need me. I don't need you. I'm
doing you a big favor. No. Let me ask
you a question. The wealthiest man on
earth,
does he have to give zakia? He has to,
right? He has to. His wealth will not be
purified without giving it correct. What
if there's not a single person on the
earth eligible for zaka? What's he going
to do then?
Huh?
What's he going to do? How is he going
to give zak?
There's no one to accept it.
built things.
[Arabic recitation]
here that is made and this is the exact
point that the prophet made sallam
to drive home that
the relationship between the one giving
the zakah and the recipient of the zakah
is mutual need of one another.
The wealthy need the poor. They need
them. They need them to give them zak.
If they don't exist, there's no one to
give charity to. Their wealth is as good
as useless.
What are you going to do with it? How
are you going to get it to Allah if
there's no one to receive it? And the
poor need the wealthy. There is no you
need me more than I need you or that
doesn't exist. The Muslim are one body.
You know, one time and I'll end with
this. I was having a question and answer
session
in an area was in Philadelphia
and there is a huge chasm between the
wealthy and the poor. The area I was in
was a very bougie, high-end place. A lot
of rich people there. And literally a
few blocks down the road were some of
the poorest Muslims you've ever seen.
And
we were having our questions answers and
it was a a fatwa a melus fetwa on on the
issue of zak
and the issue came up of
can we give we want to give our zak
and send it all back home to our
respective countries not keep it here.
And this is highly differed upon
amongst the scholars on whether that's
even valid or not.
All of the scholars agree
that belongs where in the place that
it's taken from in the community that
it's taken from it's to be circulated
amongst that community. when I take the
zaka and ship it out, what does that do
with my relationship with the Muslim
mean in my own community? Right?
So he said, she
but this is a moot point in this day and
age in this country. Mood point is said
because the government takes care of
them. The government takes care of our
Muslim brothers that are in need. We
don't have to give them anything. We
send it overseas. The government takes
care of them. They got welfare. They got
food stamps. They got wick. They got
As a as a man, would you be okay with
another man coming into your household
and taking care of your family?
[Arabic recitation]
you feel about that?
You really need it. But he steps in. He
says, "Don't worry. I I don't want your
wife or your kids, but I'm going to take
care of them from now on. You can keep
all your money. Is there any amount of
money in the world that is worth that
kind of
hit to your dignity? That's my
family. I take care of mine. Even if I
have to sweat and cry and bleed, I will
take care of my family. No one else
does.
Right?
What happened to that feeling that the
Muslim had or have that the Muslim are
one body? If one part of the body is in
pain, the rest of the body suffers with
sleeplessness
and fever. Who what what what person is
going to come and take care of my
brother? That's my brother. You don't
come and take care of my brother. He's
my responsibility. I have too much
dignity to allow anyone to take care of
my brother other than myself.
And this is what goes to a deeper
problem that we are experiencing
[Arabic recitation]